foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
what's going on you guys
get me guys here man for Lord addict
that's what you guys know me as coming
at you with another attic show we talk
about the past president future gaming
uh big Cloud's gonna be mad late like 30
minutes late he'll be here momentarily
but you know right now it's just being
dirt dirt currently
is having a car uh he's having a phone
call with uh the leader of the
PlayStation uh you know fanboyism you
know he he's apologizing for for how we
gonna act today he's apologizing for
however Gonna Act today but how you guys
doing man how you guys doing I see the
chat you know we got got 50 people in
here uh 56 actually just updated you
know I appreciate everyone for coming
through here I feel like the lighting on
my on my things a little off today I
don't know if that's just me
um I don't know why my Elgato light
isn't
registering
it's kind of weird
remind me later
it's not on my steam deck or anything
and they there's there all right I told
him I told the uh the the panel that she
was on on a phone call with the leader
of the PlayStation Fanboys apologizing
for our Behavior today yeah man I uh you
know I had to give him a disclaimer
say look guys you might not like some of
the things being said on today's show
there's no if you can just disregard
what we're saying you know just keep on
doing what you're doing you know what
I'm saying yeah see see I don't do that
though you know when I call the
PlayStation people I say deal with it
like because they tell me to deal with
with games this and that now you gonna
deal with what's happening next man all
right so like I said I appreciate it for
coming through here when we talk about
the past present future gaming uh this
is the attic show uh you know I got my
co-host with me Dirk griggity what's
going on dirt what you been playing
it ain't no surprisingly you know what
I've been playing I um
I actually booted up the last of us too
because I when I completely late in 2020
I kind of just beat it in one weekend
just kind of ran through it so I can do
a review but this time I'm going to take
my time with it and uh you know that's
why I've been playing I also been trying
to finish a large judgment and fourso
Horizon 5 DLC uh the Hot Wheels DLC so
that's what those are three games I've
been kind of playing right now that's
what's up man you know uh I've actually
been playing um
this turn-based game it's called let me
see what it's called
it's called sympathy of War
of the war
so it's pretty much like it's kind of a
weird game it's hard to explain what
this game is it's like I would say a
good accurate analogy for it's like
Final Fantasy Tactics and that Griezmann
game you know the the 16-bit out game
it's kind of like both of those uh I
can't remember exactly what that game's
called it's like green something but
it's it came to Game Pass it was
actually a popular gaming game pass but
you know that that's pretty much what
I've been playing you know got the uh I
broke my keyboard well I didn't break it
this this this 10 ton
um this 10 ton mic broke it so what
happened I was an addict I was on the
IOP
so people were complaining naturally
like they always do about not hearing me
so I was moving the mic to get closer to
me like this like so right and it came
off the desk
damn and then this bottom part here
slams straight into my keyboard
and like and then this part here like
the part that like I I turned to like
adjust it hit my mouse it it double
killed the man like if anything would
have been nice to have the dude that did
the uh the the you know the announcement
for Halo it just the moment I did all
you hear is double kill
it was it was that serious man but you
know preacher ever coming through man
like I told you we actually got a pretty
good show for you guys we got
PlayStation and Call of Duty apparently
you know uh PlayStations worried about
what's gonna happen with that Call of
Duty post acquisition with Microsoft uh
I ain't gonna lie to you I'd be worried
too I mean I'm not gonna lie then we got
superhero games at Xbox it's a little
fun topic I came together on you know
what Studios we would see like because I
feel like everyone's making a superhero
game but Xbox and I feel like needs to
be changed and then right house knew uh
they actually got a new studio and it
looks like it looks like uh red Falls
development team is helping them with it
uh so you know obviously we'll put a
little bit of everything you know these
are our general walking paths this is
like the little wooden planks on a
bridge that you walk through clearly
most of the time we fall through one and
we just talk about random [ __ ] for like
10 minutes but we trying to get better
kinda kinda uh but you know so you know
I I really first off I want to address I
I really appreciate you know the support
the attic show has been getting here uh
you know we'll be anywhere from 25 to 5
000 views a week
it's getting pretty good like I said I
do plan on um adjusting
how the podcast looks eventually
and I will be getting to that uh you
know keep in mind you know there are
great got his own shows man uh go and
follow him on those uh his is some spicy
stuff you think we spicy on here we PT
compared to dirt over there hey hey
Addie let me tell you last Monday's show
man it was so spicy the topic was so big
that we actually broke a live viewer
record you know like we don't get iron
Lord podcast numbers but we hit
561 live viewers most we've ever had
they wanted to hear us TTS bro that's
what they wanted to hear they wanted to
hear us and it was a fun show man crazy
crazy numbers you know for us crazy
numbers bro that's good you know you
guys have a good show over there you
know what it is is for the most part
people know it's just fun jokes and
games you know and you know I don't want
to go over this too much but I have
noticed that you know
people get this weird like
this weird middle ground when it comes
to content creators that are that are
funny you know they they kind of like
because you guys do kind of go on that
console more stuff where you can go left
or right pretty easy but it always stays
on the middle ground and I respect it
for it because there's a lot of people
out there dirt and I'm sure you've
noticed them that uh you know that
anything that comes up in any negative
way shape or form they always like the
addict we need to be positive like I
call them I call them
they are the
um the toxic positivity Clan yeah
because look I will say that there's a
lot of people out there especially
PlayStation Fanboys that love to hide
like to take a little issue and and
amplify it by a thousand right and but
at least there's something that
originated from that issue for them to
amplify most the time I see when these
toxic positivity people
they take they they don't they don't
hold accountable for anything you know
what I'm saying it's like oh you know
this and that that and this I'm like no
we're not talking about none of that
like stuff needs to change and we're
talking about and I feel like a lot of
people regardless if it's for
sponsorships or you know relationships
with certain people in the industry they
are willing to sideswipe their con the
concepts and what they say to the left
or right so they can maintain those
relationships I'm not going to tell you
that
I probably have been brought up multiple
times uh you know my outputs on stuff
like call uh stuff like Halo here's the
thing though
I know I ain't never hosting anything
I know I'm never gonna get that big big
like big big bag
so I'm gonna talk my talk and it's just
like you know but one thing I want to
like voice your concern with that is
like most of these places don't care
what you say as long as you say it in a
semi-respective way because there's a
difference between someone joking around
about something and then someone
personalizing someone and joking about
them
and I feel like a lot of the time you
know it's it's the latter people like to
they can't talk about Xbox without
personalizing something like Phil
Spencer or Aaron Greenberg and just
being disrespectful for no reason you
could easily get your point across and
still have a uh what's where I'm looking
for you can easily get your point across
and be respectful and still get that CR
you know that that criticism that you
want to give and people feel like it's
only one or the other sure there'll be
sometimes where I'm like you know what
I'ma let that go because clearly there I
have this rule uh dirt I don't know how
you feel about it uh people say well
addict why don't you bring that up
anymore I have this rule where if I
bring something up a couple times I'm
done with that conversation until
there's been a realistically enough time
to handle it to actually give some type
of response to it like for instance
people that talk about Xbox got no games
for two years every podcast yes
you can't realistically have them fix
that in a month but you are talking
about it every podcast that month
exactly it's just like you know we all
got to be better man you know we because
sometimes I I you know I see that that
dangling low fruit when it comes to the
console war stuff I'm like
I got to be better on that but like one
thing we got to do is we can't always
turn stuff positive because there's not
always a positive outlay that's that's
not that's not reality bro you know we
are different we all have different
styles of podcasts we all can't be the
same very griggity and Weebly green we
can't be Iron Lords podcast uh we can't
be RDX we can't be
I can only be what I'm comfortable with
and we all got to be different man we
all can't be the same so you know yeah
that's why you know at least with the
people that are on there saying the same
stuff every week
at least with their toxic stuff when
they're like Xbox got no games let's
let's just take a drill hammer to that
over and over again you know what I'm
saying at least there's some form of
Truth there that is the reason they're
doing that if XBox started launching
Starfield and it was like a 9 out of ten
and red Falls a 9 out of 10. these
people will shut up eventually you just
have to you have to like you have to
force them to submission at that point
uh but I I do feel like you know it's
like I said these other people it's like
man we can't act like there's rainbows
all the time yeah there's nine problems
like that's equivalent to like seeing
something like you know Halo infinite
and saying well they had to work in the
pandemic it's okay to acknowledge the
troubles that they had but you could
still acknowledge the issues the game is
currently having without exclusively
being one or the other and I think
that's the biggest issue like there's a
middle ground where you got the toxic
positivity people over here that don't
want to say anything outlayish and then
you've got the hugely toxic people over
here and no one wants to entertain the
middle and I think you know everyone
needs to be better at entertaining that
middle and this isn't even really on
your podcast because I don't consider
you a toxic podcast uh yeah I always
have fun I mean like some people might
but we just have fun man no there's a
difference between talks and podcasts
and and you know you you ride on the
console war wave but in a joking way
like you yeah rarely do I see you like
really like uh you know
actively attack anyone for anything and
when you do attack someone it's like
it's like huge Fanboys that we have
relationships with that they will
actually watch it like yeah I was I was
bugging
we got a uh a member chat from Bunty
15 months enough respect to Dart and IOP
addict two of my favorite Pockets hit
them up where it hurts today the truth
and then we got a two dollars from Edwin
Garcia Mystic Ryan this passively buys
towards PlayStation and that's fine see
that's different because people are
actually working at these companies like
they gotta do that like they they got to
uh you know they can't really speak on
negatives on their company because PR
would message them so fast like don't be
talking like that but that's so that's
that's my little rant for the day uh you
know you got you got anything you want
to address uh dirt I just I agree man um
you know like there's
there's a middle ground sometimes people
want to be either super negative or
super positive you know sometimes you
know there's a middle ground yeah like
you was referring to earlier um
there are so many different style of
podcasts I'm fully aware that everybody
might not like my style
but there are people that that do like
my style so you can't please everybody I
told the story uh like on my show when I
used to coach Middle School basketball I
coached for eight years
even though I was in my 30s at the time
I realized you can't please everybody
there were games where we would blow a
team out by 30 points and their team
like games we would lose to a team by 30
points no matter what happened when we
would win they'll be parents say my
child didn't play enough there
what are you doing you're a terrible
coach if we would lose oh you're just a
terrible coach why are we losing like
this and now notice you can't please
everybody there's some people you can
never please so going into this YouTube
thing I realized that early on
there's going to be some Xbox guys that
don't like my console war content
there's guys that told me their your
channel was going too console I don't
like it anymore so okay thank you man
thanks for watching peace out and
there's guys that love Mike Hunter this
PlayStation guys that hate it those
their space station guys that used to
like it don't like it anymore so you're
never going to please everybody so miles
will go with what you're comfortable
with and it's like to mention like you
know I like the Contour stuff I do feel
like you know there are people that take
it too far uh absolutely yeah but for
the most part the people in my inner
circles it's just a joking thing it's
you know when I make fun of like a
certain aspect of PlayStation it's not
because I hate PlayStation I got that
overweight thing up there yeah I still
play it I love playing it it's just got
to give me something to play it on right
now because you know Horizon went
hitting like that but it's just like you
know Xbox comes around like I remember I
had a scenario
where I was talking about Starfield and
I said yo I wanted to see more of on
Starfield last year and I will never
forget how much nonsense that I got
because I just wanted to see more on
Starfield and they're like oh addict you
know they're going to show you next year
you know and I'm like look Starfield was
announced Years Ago by Bethesda
so regardless how you feel about it
just because I want to see more star
filled shouldn't mean that I shouldn't
see more Starfield and then people I'm
tired of like there's a lot of people
that feel like there can't be both
answers are right just because you feel
like Starfield is a like last year
shouldn't have been there because you
know they still need more information on
it doesn't mean that I can't see more on
that for instance when they were talking
about the Thousand Planet stuff I said
okay maybe they're being in two
Ambitions on this and then people say
well Addie you don't know enough
information I said why can't we both be
right you know what I'm saying why can't
I'm a little nervous because they're
showing all this spanned and I'm worried
about is there actually going to be
relevant content with this span and you
could be right because we don't have
enough information and we need to see
more to really acknowledge if it's going
to be good or bad for the game and I
felt like too many people are like if I
don't agree with you you're wrong I'm
right and vice versa and people people
say where's Bitcoin big Clive will be
here you know big Cloud's late like
normal
this is like the second week in a row he
he took his sweet time coming on the
show but you know we got you the Xbox
people are always on time
you know I'm just pointing that out all
right so let's go ahead and get on uh
with uh this roundhouse new title man so
there's not a lot of information on this
uh so I didn't want to take it that way
on what we speculate this game would be
you know what I want to hear from you
dirt what do you want them to be working
on what kind of genre what type of uh
you know what kind of uh you know
viewership What type of game do you want
them making for Xbox
well roundhouse what has they made like
what's their previous games are a brand
new studio
the brand new studio okay well to be
honest with you um
the genre doesn't matter too much I
don't want a real time strategy game I'm
not a fan me personally I'm not a fan of
that genre
um I would like to see something third
person because Xbox has a lot of first
person games I would like to see a third
person action game it doesn't have to be
a a real heavy narrative
um but I just want to see something like
a banging new IP I would love if they
did a recour we make a better version of
The Recoil record so or something like
that
um because I actually like that game I
thought the IP had tons of potential so
yeah I I would like to see something a
little different not a first person
shooter not a RT uh s is it something
you know it could be a platformer in my
opinion it can be
whatever but those two genres like Xbox
has and they don't need another first
person shooter IP in my opinion
um so I would like to see something a
little different something new I
actually would like to see a platformer
I don't know why I would be fine with a
platform bro I would be absolutely I
actually feel like return over all the
snap that people just say on maternal I
feel like record would have been a very
good game if it was redone give it a
proper budget with property absolutely
people like to to attack the stuff that
record did wrong but people don't like
giving that game the stuff it did right
and I feel like look
recore
might have had a like a kind of a
generic fighting system a colored system
that didn't make sense to a lot of Point
not a lot of options in terms of
creatures wasn't a lot of bosses either
it's kind of like a Blaine desert game
with not a lot of content in it but one
thing it did do is it did have really
good platforming parts and I feel like
that's what the game should have been
built around is platforming absolutely
great platforming I actually finished
that game I I'm the only person I know
that finished that game I did oh see the
second person I ever met that finished
recoil I enjoyed that game I thought it
had really does a ton of
potential for a future XBox IEP I know
they still own the IP but I don't know
if they're going to do anything with it
but yeah I totally love recore I just
feel like when it comes to recore uh you
know they they needed to focus a little
bit more on on combat make it a little
bit more fluid you know I like the
Tuggle War thing they did in that game
yeah yeah they could have did like a
skill tree where maybe instead of like
just yanking it she uses her thing and
makes it to like a like a whip and
smacks it around her and hits everything
around you like there was just so much
they could have done if they would have
a good class system in that game you
know maybe you could have switched out
the animals for multiple different
animals that it wasn't just those three
uh not to mention they put the the
unique person in there after the game
was already dead at that point yeah so
it was like a year later wasn't it it
was about a year later it was yeah yeah
I just felt like that game had potential
and another prime example of Microsoft
not utilizing that potential uh you know
I agree I don't think they're going to
do anything with that that and rice rice
Center Rome yeah right yeah right you
know that could have easily been their
God of War two new IPS absolutely bro oh
absolutely see the thing with recoil if
you really go back and look at it it
almost seemed like the game wasn't ready
to release because that following year
like we mentioned the definitive edition
it had you see on the the original
recoil in 2016 that was a robot on the
cover of the game that just flat I
wasn't in the game
it was in the game the
like you ride on yeah the one you ride
over the sand or whatever the quicksand
it came in like that big expansion they
put that game that that robot in the
game like a year later the defensive
Edition which was the finished game so
it just seemed like at that time Xbox
just needed content so they just put
games out even though this is just a
double a game they just put it out when
it wasn't fully ready you know that was
the times I'm like that's how I was back
then unfortunately so yeah recoil was
one of those games I wish I wish they
would bring it back maybe roundhouse I
wish roundhouse would do a a record or
reimagining a recall or something but
that's just me they need record needed
kind of like a Prince of Persia
platforming style that you take into
account for all their animals and you're
taking account for the you know the
movement that she had and I felt like
they didn't never really did that it was
always one or the other the platforming
was good don't get me wrong and you did
do that some in the game but I felt like
it should have been a lot more yeah I
agree what's funny is if you look at
um you know recourse final dungeon in
that game that's some of the hardest
platforming I've ever done in gaming it
it was it was ridiculous yeah it was
crazy you know and then when you look at
Rice Center Rome it's just like you look
at that game and you're just like that
game's a very beautiful game and it had
so much potential
so much potential that I actually felt
like
you know you give it a good you give it
a good story you really built up the
lore of the game you could have even won
it from you know
it was that Rice Center Road thing and
you could have
put gods in it it could have literally
been in its own God of War like and once
again Microsoft that was at a time where
they wasn't really valuing what other
people made for them they wanted uh what
they were making for themselves they
wanted other people to make stuff and
yeah
and they bit them in the butt it's
disappointing that's one of the biggest
issues I've had you know for a long time
is they will contract second party
people to make a game and then after
that contract is over they're like oh
okay and I heard that Rice Center rum
too was actually in development and then
they were fighting over who owned the IP
I heard that also that Microsoft or Xbox
and cry Tech they I heard that Xbox
wanted to buy the IP and cry Tech didn't
want to let them to buy the IP so I
don't know maybe some friction happened
there
um I'm not sure if they're on good terms
now maybe there's they are but at one
point maybe they weren't on good terms
so and you know crazy what happened from
the outcry of them not letting Microsoft
buy that IP nothing they have an IP they
ain't done nothing with uh you you know
they don't make like merchandising tools
or anything like that because there
ain't no merchandise for that game
really like it's just like you know
there's a couple IPS that Microsoft owns
I would really like to have seen more of
uh you know rise is one of them recourse
one of them I would have really liked to
see a banjo I think they could really do
something with banjo I would like to see
some form of a party game with all of
their IPs being like icons where you can
like play the game as banjo or or you
know Doom guy like they got so many
stuff they don't even have to do like a
Super Smash Bros like a Mario Party type
of game yeah I feel like they would
actually do really well in that area but
I don't know maybe maybe right now micro
this office and you know we got to make
sure we get these games that
they were that you know Bethesda was
making at that time and then we got to
make sure that Bethesda the games that
come out after that are good too
absolutely because clearly they had
maybe a next game that was in mine and
I'm sitting here looking at like a
scenario uh like you like Multiverse is
talking about and the chat someone
brought up the Warner bro has Multiverse
exactly Microsoft that could have been
them that could have been their game
it just I do feel like sometimes these
multi-billion dollar corporations get
lost touch and if they don't see making
money immediately they don't green light
it
and I'm not saying that people don't
need to make money money makes the world
go wrong I'm saying sometimes you need
to build a foundation or something
before you get the real money later
right right and I and you know it is
what it is with that is there any games
that you would like Microsoft to revive
that they own ah well I just said one
with recore
um
excuse me well if they don't own the
right side people I wish they did
because I would love I would love that
um man like you said there's so much IP
they own now and just imagine after
Activision Blizzard goodness
um after activities but after Activision
Blizzard I would like it true crime
remake you know because I love that both
of those games back in the day I'm not
sure you know if they would do that
because GTA those style of games isn't
as popular as it was doing well you know
you know what you do with uh True Crime
what's that you make that into a third
person like action game that's kind of
like on the same versus like unchartered
and stuff where it's a it doesn't have
like a huge open world that you go
through oh that's really linear but I
feel like you know imagine you in Japan
fighting fighting through Japan or like
you know I'd like to see more games that
that go off the villain side
of like you know you playing as a
villain from a young age and you finally
understanding why they are by the time
they get the older age you know what I'm
saying yeah yeah I mean I'm down for
that man but they have so much so many
IP even if they you know even though
it's funny if you think about pitfall
Activision owns Pitfall right which was
literally the first
Tomb Raider or Uncharted gang you know
it was just like
eventually maybe they could do something
without IP you know you never know a
good old Pitfall game so yeah there's um
tons of Ip Man like I just said banjo
would be cool
um recore nah man I can't even think of
it off the top of my head bro there's so
many IP they own now that that's sad
that's why I'm okay with them buying
like these giant companies because I'm
hoping you know as long as they don't
keep everyone on Call of Duty and I
think they are going to keep a lot more
of these Studios on Call of Duty than
people think I think they are too yeah I
agree with you yeah I think they're
gonna free maybe one or two of them up
but I think the vast majority of them
are still going to work on Call of Duty
I agree yeah because I think a lot of
these people want to work on Call of
Duty I don't think people realize that
Call of Duty is a very job security type
of game as long as you don't mess up and
do everything you're supposed to you're
never going to realistically run out of
work Call of Duty is infinite pretty
much like it I they never run out of
stuff to do like because there's always
a war that went on in the past that you
can reimagine there's always some future
war that you could create like you
literally could do anything with that
brand and I think that absolutely
earlier you know a lot of people feel
you know secure with that type of
gameplay yeah
I actually you know not to get off it a
little bit because I know we're gonna
talk about you know Activision uh
slightly in the final topic but I would
actually what do you want them to do
with the pre-existing stuff that they
own with Call of Duty Not Call of Duty
necessarily because I don't think
they're going to do a whole lot with
that I think that's going to stay around
the same but as far as their other stuff
that Activision owns what would you
prefer them to do if any of that
I would like well at first off let me
say I agree with you I think they're
going to keep a lot of those teams on
Call of Duty what they've been doing for
a while but I think the occasional team
like Bob's uh Toys for Bob
I think that's the studio that might go
off and do something maybe another
platform or maybe another crash because
I'm saying crash four Crash Bandicoot 4
was an underrated Gem of a game that
game was awesome and not a lot of people
cared unfortunately
um so Toys for Bob I would love to see
them do a like another platform I read
they're about to do they're doing
something I believe that studio
specifically is doing something
um but yeah you think hot is huge
I would like for them to
I don't know would you like for them to
bring back Guitar Hero somehow no that
could say so far
well I'm not gonna say okay you know if
they what about Tony Hawks if they bring
it back it is what it is but I do feel
like I don't want to see a Guitar Hero
game like me personally if they brought
it back and people actually really Vibe
with it whatever
what I would like is them to make a
spiral and crash game together yeah uh
it would be cool if like you know they
have a cohesive story between the both I
think it would be cool if you had a
Crash Bandicoot game a badger Kazooie
somehow together because they both got
like the the companion with them yeah I
think it would be interesting uh but you
know obviously those are those are uh
really out of outstretch I think if
Microsoft was smart when they secured
this play state of this this card deal
and uh secured this Activision though
I don't know why I always always want to
call called Activision Activision calls
when they secured the Activision though
they would keep
crash and Rebrand it as like a huge part
of like the icon for Xbox like wherever
that Xbox brand is you want to put him
in there somewhere because I don't think
people especially younger audiences
they don't realize the importance in the
past of Crash Bandicoot
right they don't know a huge important
game absolutely and I think a Crash
Bandicoot game uh you know even even if
it's something small like you know
they need that as a mascot I think crash
would be a fantastic mascot spiral was
important back then but not nearly as
important as crash crash was just this
is way bigger crash was probably the
grandfather of platforming that right
like kind of like jump started just like
I think Halo is one of the the
grandfathers for for first person
shooters now is it the most important
shooter maybe for console gaming it was
because I do think Halo made console
gaming a lot more
a death but I don't think it was that
important in the grand scheme of things
I actually think Call of Duty was more
important to first-person shooters than
Halo because I think you know what about
doom doom dude here's the thing Doom's
good but I think Call of Duty made it
mainstream that's right I think at the
end of the day
it's not 99 anymore addicts I'm not
saying look someone's talking about my
crash look
I'm not saying that they need to do it
I'm saying that Crash Bandicoot is such
a recognizable thing with a lot of
people they might not know what that
dude's name is but there's a lot of
casual people you show them Crash
Bandicoot and they're gonna recognize it
maybe not the name but they're going to
recognize the actual person
40 year old kids uh Eric the beard you
you you serious why hey remember crash
crash was the one guy that ran up on
Mario remember that commercial where
crash was uh oh he's at like Nintendo
head headquarters and he had the
megaphone it was calling out Mario do
you remember that commercial I know
you're a little bit younger than me but
you know what would be crazy someone
just brought up a good point a crash
verse
imagine if you felt like remember how
Donkey Kong 64 had where you could
switch between characters and every area
had like a certain unique aspect that a
platform that only a certain characters
do imagine if the next like five years
toys for started building a crash first
with spiral and a Banjo-Kazooie Crash
Bandicoot conquer
and they put all these people in this
one universe and then in five years
after they've made a few of these days
because keep in mind these games don't
cost that much to make and keep in mind
at the end of all this you make an IT
you make a a donkey called 64 Style game
with all of them in it
I think it would be lit now sure are
these games gonna sell well probably not
but here's the thing Microsoft can't
come out openly over and over again say
we like game pass because it gives us
more opportunities to take risks but
then don't do any risks right it makes
no sense so that's pretty much all we
got for that one man like I said
um I think
I think that they have a lot of
opportunity uh hopefully we'll see
something from this studio that's pretty
relatively good I'm very curious man uh
so next topic we got uh you know
superheroes are everywhere man they're
literally everywhere I'm sure you've
seen them too apparently another Studio
from EA's uh supposedly working on a
Black Panther game
so I started thinking Dart am I bugging
for thinking that everyone's getting
superhero games but Microsoft likes no
no I don't think you bug him
um I just think me personally I think
that
I think Phil Spencer is in a point where
he
they want to own
those huge properties because in the
past they've got been in the butt by
putting out a game
and not able to do a sequel because they
didn't own those properties
if they bought a WB or something or you
know I don't know if they can even get
the license the license to the
superheroes but this is just my opinion
of course I just think Phil wants to own
these these huge games they're going to
either be third party
or they or he wants to own them because
if you don't own it it can be a Sunset
Overdrive even though Sunset overdraft
didn't kill it it was out it was
released and they left to go do
something else Spiderman
they're like like rice I'm around you
know we just talked about I I just
believe Phil wants to own the IP own the
property I don't think he wants to you
know yeah okay we'll do one one game
yeah now
people might not agree with it but
that's my opinion about it I just think
he just doesn't he just doesn't want to
you know own it and then they leave and
do something else or the studio gets
bought out you know there's so many
instances of like if you think about
Crackdown three they have that team that
was doing the Cloud Tech and they got
acquired by was it Epic
epic or Facebook somebody yeah so then
that pretty much they had to do it
themselves and he saw how it turned out
they
they got bitten about way too many times
of working on the game or worked on the
game and the sequel couldn't be done
because the teams that developed left I
don't think he wanted to do that uh you
know
this is my opinion not saying that's
right but that's what I think yeah I
agree with you I don't think he for the
most part I think he wants to work
in-house for everything I think at any
point he wants to pick up the phone and
if a head of a studio doesn't want us to
be working on he said okay then I can
replace you I still get what I want it's
just you're not doing it anymore
um you know it used to be if you talk to
a studio like that and you had no
leverage over them they would just go do
what they want and I'm not saying that
you know he's he's idling for like power
or anything like that like he's power
hungry I think Phil's tired of losing
IPS and losing these potential you know
huge IPS that they could have nurtured
because the studio don't want to do them
uh so now it's like you know people say
well stop making your studio work on one
game I don't think Phil's really
focusing on anything like that look look
I don't mind a a studio working on one
or two games and that's all because
Microsoft owns so many now because
remote access and remote games uh you
know remote work has become so
accessible that if you could just pick
up the phone call your your you know
your HR and say yo after this game I'm a
little burnt out on Halo okay can I
transfer and work on maybe Fable and
finish and help them finish that and if
there's a position opening they can make
that happen like I think Microsoft is
like one of the only studies that offer
you this kind of variety and games right
like a developer as long as there's
access to remote work you can literally
work on any genre almost in the industry
absolutely yeah absolutely because
they're working remotely like you don't
have to relocate to another city another
state no you're working at the comfort
of your own home you're absolutely right
about that man yeah and I also think
that that being said I do agree that
even though he doesn't want to do it I
still think he needs to uh you know you
got micro you got Sony potentially
making their own
Marvel Universe in their friend in their
games because you know we don't know if
Spider-Man and Wolverine are going to be
connected in the in the gaming universe
but I can almost guarantee you they are
like I can almost guarantee you they are
and then what you know I don't know
anything about comic books but you know
whatever group that those two belong to
because I don't know enough about you
know their universes to know they can
eventually spawn like their own Avengers
moment in the future where they they get
a couple characters together and then
they make them together and they they
form a group game and it's just like
that game's going through so well yeah
that game is going to move consoles and
to me it's like the Fallout 4 5 moment
people disagree with me on that I'm not
saying that Fallout needs they need
Fallout 5. I'm saying that that is such
a big movement such a big game
don't wait till after Sky uh Elder
Scrolls 6 to decide that you want a
Fallout fight because by then
might be too late
and it's just like look like you know we
got to do better with vocalizing you
know I get tired when I say something
like that people say oh who are you to
demand us or demand people to make games
I'm not demanding anything I'm just
pointing something out uh there's a lot
of people that like fantasy stuff that's
where Elder Scrolls comes in and there's
a lot of people that are like modern day
stuff that could happen look Fallout got
mutants and stuff in it chances are
that's not hugely realistic but we don't
know what a nuclear war gonna bring
either so like look like I do think
like I said I I will die on this hill
I'm attic is on this hill and he he got
a bazooka come come mess with me because
this hill is lit you know I got traps on
this hill you what's what what's uh
think about a movie where people are
going up something and there's nothing
but traps and the whole points get to
the top a lot that's my Hill my Hill is
trapped all right so I'm willing to stay
on this hill as long as it takes for you
to get me off of it they need to make
Fallout five
at the same time that they make Elder
Scrolls six I don't care if Bethesda
doesn't make it you know if you want to
make it a KOA I personally think I have
said it on the show it needs to be a
co-op experience two Studios need to be
working on that game my preferred world
would be Bethesda and obsidian you could
do the same thing with this these type
of games just because you don't need
a superhero game and at the end of the
day the grand scheme of things they
probably don't need one
doesn't mean they shouldn't give you one
right
yeah I mean
if you look at what Sony is doing yeah
well if that's the case maybe they
should do one but
at the same time I just think Phil wants
to own it man I don't think you want the
lights and stuff out you know when it
comes to Game Pass he wants to make sure
A Game Pass is their IP
is their game and they can keep it in
Game Pass as long as they want
they don't have to you know worry about
it leaving Game Pass or the contract
ended the game has to go no no I just
think Phil wants to focus on Xbox IP
because like you mentioned earlier man
those deals that Don metric made in the
Xbox 360 generation
they came back to kick Xbox in the butt
they don't want to do that they've
learned from that
they had great games you know Bio Shock
was exclusive for a year uh like the
first Mass Effect was actually exclusive
but what happened they didn't bite sorry
so it's an attic has The High Ground
when I was talking about my my mountain
in the house people are ridiculous it's
funny
um
like I said the first Mass Effect was a
exclusive
but what happened they didn't own them
buy aware got picked up by EA so every
Mass Effect after that was a multi-plat
so they learned over the years you can't
you know just do all of these second
party deals and eventually what happened
was the Xbox one generation even though
the first three years was quality as far
as software
when Insomniac left to do something they
didn't make a deal with crytek all of
those games they you know had the timed
exclusivity of Tomb Raider
none of those games were sequels their
next game was never on the Xbox
exclusively because these deals they
made in the past came back to bite them
in the butt and Phil Spencer mentioned
this that he doesn't you know he wanted
to make sure things are done in-house
like you said whether we like that or
not
it is what it is bro
yeah we can't we can't make stuff happen
but what I will say is like I said I
understand why Phil does what he does
when it comes to this because uh but I
do think that the problem wasn't the
fact that they didn't own stuff the
problem was they solely relied on them
owning it backs
that's true it's got one or two games
being made
that's not in-house then make it
relevant you know you know make it games
that matter if for instance a superhero
okay there's so many opportunities out
there you got this Blade game that uh
blade movie that's coming out like I
think it's the end of next year like
yeah start working on a blade game it's
not like and not to mention you can make
it we need a third person you know
action adventure game you can hit two
birds with one stone
you know have the Coalition make a like
uh make a a Punisher game gory like
because that's what the kind of
character he is it makes sense for them
to make it you know and that that's the
only thing it's just like dude come like
I get it people think that you know
I just don't like the mindset
that just because they don't want it in
the how the uh you know the
overall aspect that like that's how it
should be it's just like I honestly feel
dirt that it could happen everyone can
get what they want yo and I think it
could easily be that way everyone can
get what they want we get the same uh
you know aspect I think that you know
right now we're not saying much because
there's not a lot going on but dirt tell
me what happens when Sony does in like
maybe five to ten years that's that's a
long time but you know in gaming wise
that's not you know imagine five to ten
years you start seeing
this world that micros that Sony's been
trying to build this cinematics world
where you know you got the uh you got uh
Wolverine in it then you're gonna have
Spider-Man it's rumored that they have
another game that they're working on
imagine a scenario where all of these
games come in share a universe and then
they start hitting their their Avengers
in the movies moments it's just like if
we thought Spider-Man was was a struggle
and Wolverine's going to be a struggle
imagine when you start seeing their
Avengers pop up
like that but at that time if you don't
make stuff now and that that's like
theoret that's they're uh theorizing
that they're doing this I think it's a
pretty good safe bet to say that it's
pretty obvious they did yeah so
if you don't make steps now to at least
have those type of games not necessarily
maybe you can't get your own Marvel
Universe because Sony probably have some
kind of back deal with Marvel saying
look we only making yo games and if like
if it's over on our platform it's
exclusive because if you noticed ever
since that happened you don't really see
anything exclusive
to anywhere else besides before they
started making those Spider-Man deals
and those Wolverine deals like it's like
it's like I bet you 20 bucks you know
I'm never gonna be able to prove it
because they never come out I bet you
they have first refusal Clauses that
says oh Gotham Knights that don't look
that that don't look like I style they
can do that oh we don't need that like
because it's just like to me you don't
see Marvel anymore you don't even see
the generic stuff you know what I'm
saying you don't see the the three or
four bad Spider-Mans anymore like it's
just like oh hold on now we just had two
marble games job in the last two years
and they were but bad they were duds
they were solid games no but no no no no
these games were in development for
years like years and years probably
three to five years yeah of course you
know
they were still AAA games tonight's as a
DC property so you can't really count
them I'm surprised Microsoft hasn't done
anything with that got into the DC Road
and that I think that's just my my
biggest thing it's like you know if you
can't be look I'm not saying I've always
been Cog is huge on the tax tag just
once
I'm not really there I'm like yo you
technically get that hellblade you get
that with uh Gears of War uh compulsions
making one they have like just three
like but you know Carl you know he feels
like the PlayStation audience that they
want brand new experiences I ain't about
that I'm like look they played five on
Chargers like like two Last of Us is
like clearly they don't care to play the
same experience over and over again so
that's that's just my thing and it's
just like if you don't start the the
planning processes now and you make
maybe you go up to DC and like yo we
gonna buy WB
and we're going to buy WB or at least
Rocksteady
what kind of deal can we make to make
our own Cinematic Universe because we're
gonna do in games which you guys have a
hard time doing in in the movies we're
gonna make good long-term ideals for
comic books when it comes to the DVC DC
uh platform and it's just like that's
what I that's where I'm at it's like
they need to start making arrangements
now because once those Avenger type
games start coming out in five to ten
years at that point it's it's it's an
it's a wrap there's nothing you can do
yeah but I'm surprised you won't have a
Batman uh game even rumor it's like an
actual true true Batman game after the
success of the Batman yeah yeah so I I
don't consider Gotham Knight's Batman
game I consider that something else this
is that that ain't it I ain't claiming
that yeah you know I'm I'm really
curious how these superhero these future
superhero games are going to be because
as The Avengers which wasn't a bad game
I just think it being games out the
service totally just ruined that game
for me that and yeah they just yeah I
think it was a decent game man it had
decent Graphics a decent gameplay
but like with the Avengers and Guardians
of the Galaxy
those games AAA games
excuse me was a dud
we're hearing how people's not really
feeling Gotham Knights
we're hearing Suicide Squad we don't
know anything about suicide squad so I'm
kind of like being a superhero game
isn't a guaranteed hit I think when it
comes to Insomniac and Spider-Man
they're in the League of Their Own right
now now I don't
part of me agrees with you but the other
part of me is like I feel like
Rocksteady makes
a flash game or makes a Superman game as
Superman will probably be a little bit
harder because uh because Superman can
fly
I feel like they're gonna hit that you
know because because they got that
formula down in a lot of ways Spider-Man
copied some of Batman's formula so it's
just like to me it's like look you can't
get number one which I'm here to tell
you uh Microsoft tried to buy insomnia
but that wasn't going through and that's
probably what led to to Sony buying and
Sony at because they're like oh man we
we should get them before Microsoft does
because people don't realize like look
just because you make initial uh in
statements doesn't mean that they won't
re read down and double down in like six
months to a year trying to get them
again like okay I sent you a later
intent I want to buy you for 200 million
dollars they say no people act like
Microsoft can't send it with double the
money in six months so so that that's
why Sony's like let's just buy them now
because we might not have the
opportunity in six months from now uh so
it's just like what do you think big
cloud because we've got a lot for me and
dirt like as far as Xbox and superhero
do you think that's something that they
need or you think it's what is it a
necessity to you or is it an obligation
that you feel like they owe to their
fans so I've said this multiple times
they need a superhero the more you let
Sony just literally become the genre by
itself as the only box where you can get
these crazy AAA
um characters like superhero characters
on their system you put yourself in a
bubble at this point rockstead he's not
making you know Batman anymore they're
done it moves on they're doing suicide
squad
you would think at a time like this
Microsoft would have done something and
was like Hey guys listen we want Batman
we need to get Batman to compete against
Spider-Man we need to guess uh Superman
to compete against this you know I mean
hell without Microsoft I would have done
this right when the Justice League was
being brought back for the Schneider
verse I would have had something being
worked on but no we we don't have that
and the thing about Sony even with uh
Spider-Man we you know this is why I
think the Avengers is happening because
they threw in every snippet that they
possibly could that yes there are more
characters in their Arsenal that they
can definitely bring to the real world
we saw the wakandan envious Embassy we
saw Avengers Tower we saw
um Matt Murdoch's business card AKA
Daredevil we saw all this stuff in the
game they have so many characters they
can choose from that I'm not surprised
by whatsoever Wolverine is going to be
the next tier and pushing that forward
and when we get and once Wolverine's
done and we get to the X-Men who's to
say we don't see
um a black panther a true Black Panther
game depending on what model of uh does
right who says we won't get a black
panther or a daredevil
the possibilities are there
I hear you we have uh two dollars from
Tech money Sony and Marvel at odds
that's why you see EA that is another
like little little thing about like EA
still they you gotta got it easy like
they get to make Star Wars games they
get to make Marvel games like it's like
EA I'm wondering if when like
there was more to that contract where
they had something to leverage against
Disney to where they could still retain
at least the rights to make those type
of games because it's kind of crazy they
can make both
yeah it is kind of crazy they can make
Star Wars and Marvel games considering
who who made Marvel Avengers
considering how bad that game did that
you know they it's just it's kind of
crazy when you when you look at them
like Battlefront did bad uh you know I
don't know maybe Battlefront 2 saved
itself at the end but it's like
Battlefront 2 came out really bad then
you got something like Marvel Avengers
uh you know you got occasional gyms like
Guardians of the Galaxy but for the most
part Marvel games haven't been the
greatest
at all like you know you got a handful
to the style man that's what it comes
down to
I I feel you on that and that's why I
feel like you know people sit there and
they say stuff like addicts I wanted
them to buy I'll be real with you to
this day I don't want them to buy
Activision
uh you know I feel like Activision is
it's a money play it's not a build your
brand play it's just a push Game Pass
well it's not even just that like it can
push Game Pass I'm not sure
I'm saying that explain that building
their weaknesses it does Zero To None I
know I feel like a WB or a Sega made
more sense to build weaknesses uh you
know especially WB like I might be 100
to buy something like uh like Sega
because I feel like they're really
lacking in the eastern part of the of
the world but WB you get you get another
realm to make uh Killer Instinct uh you
most likely you'll be able to retain
that uh Marvel uh the Mortal Kombat
license and brand so you can you can
lease that out to make movies good
movies don't give them to whoever made
that last movie
yeah and then well that was that was HBO
Warner Brothers wasn't it yeah
yeah
I heard that's getting they're doing a
sequel yeah let me wait let me ask you
this though D I think uh Camara brought
this up for before with Sony uh with you
guys and I said you know Sony relied on
Call of Duty as a crutch for their
multiplayer solution do you guys think
Microsoft's going into that direction
now because this is going to be like
their main poster boy for Game Pass do
you think that's going to be yes look
that as a crutch you think so okay so
explain this the question again do you
think Microsoft's using is going to use
them as a crutch yeah uh Call of Duty as
a crutch I don't think they're going to
use them as a crutch I think they're
going to use like a crutch is something
that you to me a crutches something that
is a weakness but you refuse to
acknowledge because you have something
to to cover it like if anything I felt
like maybe they used Halo for years as a
crutch because they didn't feel like
they needed a double down on the
multiplayer aspect because in terms of
multiplayer factions they had gears
which is the third person they have
first person which was Halo maybe them
were crutches so they did didn't try
anything more in those veins
but as far as Call of Duty I think they
know that they know that Call of Duty is
going to be on multiple platforms so I
don't think they really have an issue
with like that issue with you know uh
the brand because it's still going to be
everywhere and they're still going to
make money but I think they're planning
on using Call of Duty as the end-all
be-all
instead of seeing the Call of Duty
uh instead of seeing a Call of Duty
where it says like you know that the gay
pass in Call of Duty are going to be
side by side everywhere you go
absolutely and I think that's they might
have look they got a lot of stuff when
they bought Activision and I I will say
that Activision didn't 100 didn't help
their brand but there's very little
things that did like buying King was
able to help them Bridge a little bit
more into the mobile market they also
had uh you know some of the most
competitive uh what's a games as a
service stuff that you that money can
buy OverWatch
so they got some Platformers so it
didn't help them but as far as the big
weaknesses that's what I'm talking about
so look Activision is a good fit for
Microsoft because there is not one
shooter that's more recognizable than
Call of Duty
and you know you you could argue like
valorant these days because I know
that's getting really really big but
it's just like regardless how much money
valorant makes and how much you know
Valerie's
the definition of a hardcore game
and I think that people need to realize
that when it comes to Call of Duty
anybody can pick up them sticks anybody
and I think that's that's their goal
their goal is you go into a Game Stop
and keep in mind they invested in a
GameStop last year
yeah so you could tell me all you want
that there's not some like little behind
the curtain language that's been going
on at GameStop
there got to be something
they upgraded all their stuff so I
wouldn't be surprised you start walking
in to to GameStop stores and you start
seeing PlayStation uh in the back Xbox
in the front you started oh that was
that's what's happening now yeah you
start seeing Xbox in the front now you
start seeing like uh you know the people
that work at GameStop employees start
pushing Game Pass and pushing uh pushing
oh you know what do you think you know
what are you a person of value did how
many kids do you have oh we got a good
service for you we got this Xbox series
s back here in the back you know does
your son like Call of Duty oh he does
well all you have to do is buy this 299
console and you can leave right here
with every Call of Duty that's ever been
made does your son like Call of Duty
he's about to get a [ __ ] done of it
when you get to the midnight releases a
lot of people instead of walking out
with collector's edition they can walk
out of the console
in the game
listen man
Game Pass is probably
75 of the reason they bought activism
blizzard in my opinion the other the
remaining 25 percent
is you know Phil mentioned this before
he didn't want
one of these huge companies like apple
or Amazon coming to the gaming industry
um if they would have came in and bought
Activision Blizzard because we heard
that activism blizzard actually reached
out to Facebook
turned them down they reached out to
Microsoft and
we're here now uh so Phil said that he
don't want these other companies to come
into the gaming industry and disrupt
things too much
um we know Sony knows how to how to do
gaming we know Nintendo know how to do
gaming and here we have Xbox so they're
at the point they just want to make sure
the big three
um holds on to the studios because who
to know if Apple would have came to the
game industry bought activism blizzard
what would have happened then who knows
man um so I just think that game pass is
the number one reason like you guys just
said adding you just explained like
painting a perfect picture of a child in
Christmas of 2023 yes do you love Call
of Duty every single Call of Duty ever
created is in Xbox game pass for a low
monthly price of ten dollars a month or
whatever you know so yeah I do believe
that's their main goal because they're
they're trying to continue to grow the
service is is doing well now and they
want to make sure it continues to do
well and oh man and adding call to duty
that's huge man it's really huge you
know what's crazy about it too
Game Pass once that's aired out and you
know you get a lot more of these games
coming out
it's an easy sell at GameStop walk up to
someone what kind of game you like the
moment they tell you you could pick a
game that Microsoft is making and run
with it oh you like Racers or you we got
the uh you know Microsoft got this Halo
4 is a Halo Horizon game oh you you like
sports games well you know Microsoft
makes deals with EA to get EA play in
there like oh you you like comic book
games well we're gonna have to go over
here to this PlayStation wall but you
know
it's just you know that's the biggest
thing when it comes to that man it's
just like look I I want what's best for
the brand and I feel like
back to like the original topic with the
superhero stuff like if you don't start
working on stuff soon by the time it's
relevant it's not going to be relevant
it's not going to be as in battle yeah
and it's just like imagine if they would
have okay once when Spider-Man came out
in what 2018
yeah they went okay they got that we're
probably not going to mess with Marvel
because of that you know what we're
going to do though we're gonna go over
here
we're gonna talk to this person about
making a spawn game
and you know they get a good developer
on it
than this year at E3 spawn coming out
next year
see did that mean when I say somewhere I
get behind that especially after seeing
that Mortal Kombat remember that I know
you remember the Mortal Kombat reveal
trailer for spawn yeah what Mal Bossier
in the background come on when y'all saw
that y'all know damn well you wanted to
see that in full-fledged game four can I
say something though see in my opinion
spawn listen man no he's got something
fun wouldn't move the needle man the
weird listen we're
in the 90s
punishment Punisher is more recent they
had a Netflix show more recently spawn
wouldn't move the needle in my opinion
yeah Spider-Man
any other big marble uh uh games IPS
well not even that because even that
Avenger game was a dud Spider-Man Batman
Superman
I think there's only a handful of
superheroes that will move the needle
that game was fantastic nobody cared
yeah nobody cared yep you got a point
spawn would not move the needle
uh maybe to us yes but to a 23 year old
who the hell is spawn
I feel like if the game was bad enough
it would move the needle I said you know
I wouldn't what you got the gore you got
the crazy set pieces with the clown uh
it definitely wouldn't move the needle
what about a Superman game
as well I know a lot of people say it's
not possible but it's like it is
possible you just don't have them face
humans haven't face demons invading the
world or have them or or have it a
couple years before or after I'm sorry
uh him getting his powers and it's like
you know doomsday invading girth or
something
well yeah yeah Superman would be huge
man I'll kill you on that like I do
understand where you're coming from or
like so what they got to spawn if it
doesn't you know engage interest and
really hype up the fan base to play the
game then at that point does it matter
and you're not wrong but my point is I
don't know if they can really go to
Marvel like that I don't know if they
can like maybe that's one of the reasons
that they haven't done it because they
may not have had conversations with
Marvel and maybe added just here's the
thing people don't realize what that
with that Spider-Man movie license
values at Marvel like when Marvel oh oh
you want somebody has leverage bro yeah
you want to make a a Marvel game I don't
know let me let me let me reach out to
the to the higher ups and the person
that Disney that he's like nah they said
that they don't want Spider-Man they
don't want nothing related to Spider-Man
I don't care
it's like last thing I need to do is
give a game to Microsoft for them to
make exclusive and then Sony hit me up
at the next uh the next meeting when
whenever this next Spider-Man license
ends and they have to renew it again I
was like we fill a little way that you
let Microsoft make it's like you don't
want to say like people don't realize
how much money that movie licensing is
it means a lot man it means a lot like
literally Sony could probably walk in
to Disney and say after this licensing
is up let's say they did make up a blade
or a Black Panther game
Sony could walk in there and say we are
going to take our Spiderman go home
unless you pull those license after that
game's up
and what what realistic and that might
be the reason that they're not really
doing because
what realistic thing can can can a
Disney or Microsoft do at that point the
most realist thing they can do is go to
DC
you know I I get what you're saying
DC I get what you're saying that Batman
I feel like in DC and maybe that Wonder
Woman game depending on how it does is
the only games that can move the needle
there's not much in DC that pops almost
everything doesn't pop like yeah I mean
like you can't you can't do it like a
Blue Beetle game and nobody would care
about that that Batman Beyond you got
Batman you got flash you got Wonder
Woman you got what else Aquaman's gotten
a lot of uh publicity but it has to be
Jason Momoa plan yeah
it checks that play you know why is
it
yeah you saw the words out my mind right
there Red Hood
I after playing Batman what was it the
Arkham Arkham Knight
someone said I want that as a game
someone said I don't think Sony can
legally blackmail Marvel it's not about
blackmailing anything it's about coming
into a meeting and saying look we are
competitor to this entity and you want
this brand how much do you want it I
mean clearly you saw you saw they were
Disney was willing to let that go and
walk out
and they did that strategic people think
they did that because they didn't want
the Spider-Man right no they did that to
prove a point to Sony and Sony called
their Bluff and what the hell happened
two months later they came right the
hell back to me I said okay what's
what's a good other Middle Ground so
let's keep it in place let's give it a
buck in terms of movies and dollar sells
for a superhero who prints more money
than Spider-Man
nothing very much nobody
that is the ace cards that is the Ace
card that's always been the ace card
character yep
um Captain America came close but he's
not you know what Iron Man's Come Close
he's not Spider-Man the sad maybe Static
Shock
but here I'm not saying like here's the
thing most likely I don't think they're
gonna get anything Marvel related until
they prove me wrong and have a Marvel
related exclusive that's that's my
stance on the matter uh so they're gonna
have to take the little
the The Little Gems that's around them
that are dirty as hell don't they don't
shine because no one knows who they are
so you're looking at stuff like spawn
you're looking at stuff like static shot
because I feel like these these Heroes
they're not big enough to be that
Spider-Man but they have a little bit of
of what's what I'm looking for notoriety
to actually okay maybe we can make them
work
let me get this five dollars super trap
from King Metro Chan
I have nephews who are younger than 22
that love spawn just because of Mortal
Kombat 11 which he had a standalone game
I agree with you on that yeah they play
more comment but we have established and
I think the numbers really point that
out that the Mortal like fighting in
general is a niche market and just
because you're willing to play a fighter
you know it would have to be a really
good spawn game and that's the thing
like
if Microsoft ever does do a spawn guy or
any type of superhero game it's got to
be good because if Microsoft does a
superhero game and it's bad they might
as well just shut that whole superhero
thing down it's never happened
hey but you said something about Sony
you said the Sony
they're really using their leverage by
owning the movie rights because think
about this when that Avengers game come
out they negotiated a deal
to make Spider-Man exclusive DLC because
I'm assuming Sony thought that game was
going to be a hit monster most people
thought that Avenger game is going to be
huge anything with Avengers in it was
selling like was guaranteed to sell
that's what they saw yeah that's what
they saw and then you hear about this
midnight is it mom was Midnight Sun that
Spider-Man is available on all platforms
because they I'm assuming Sony that yeah
you know we you could put Spider-man on
Xbox in that game who cares it's not
that I don't think Sony can stop them
from doing game iterations of Spider-Man
but unless it's something that is going
to hurt Sony's bottom line I don't think
they're gonna actually do anything like
when they thought the Marvel Avengers
game was going to do well they use that
Spider-Man to leverage like what can you
do for PlayStation because like people
can act like look stuff like that
happens all the time in the corporate
world the thing is you don't hear about
it like people are always in leveraging
behind closed doors what they gonna do
if you act out a turn like but it's
never made publicly because most of the
time those threats that's done behind
closed doors is enough to keep both
parties in check
that's true yeah
hey people said I thought Microsoft was
rumored to have multiple Disney IPS yeah
probably maybe a Star Wars game maybe
yeah that's not maybe maybe
Indiana Jones is one of them but like
we're talking about the biggest Revenue
that movies has seen in decades
yep and it's growing every year and if
you're on this train my thing is my if
Microsoft can't get on this train then
Microsoft can't get on this train yeah
but if Microsoft is refusing to pay the
toll to get on the train that is the
issue then I have well it's like look if
you physically can't get on the train
because you're Microsoft and you've been
outlawed to walk on to get on the train
okay there ain't nothing you could do
but if you can get on it but you don't
want to spend the the money it takes to
get on the train then I feel like right
then you're not seeing the bigger
picture
yeah
especially with uh it's crazy because
this is the first movie wasn't like a
crazy box office dealer right but Doctor
Strange multi Multiverse or bad this is
another one that's getting into that
billion you know sales range I mean it's
it's only going to get more expansive
but more bigger as we go Guardians you
have spot um I suppose you have a blade
coming out you have Moon Knight
She-Hulk
Sony's already like in the best just you
think about it right now to do whatever
the hell they want
they really are and that's it's only so
many games they can make though man it's
taking three or four years to make a
game they can't make all of them I mean
you know what I'm saying yeah think
about it this they actually can but they
can put it in one and make you a proper
Avengers
I don't like you're gonna you're gonna
get all the the key characters done
first for example you got Spiderman
right you got Mouse seen the villains
there you got Venom right that's gonna
introduce in part two
now if you go further you got Wolverine
what's Wolverine gonna bring Hulk more
than likely that's gonna bring obviously
the X-Men right that's another set of
characters what do you do after this
you can either backtrack and scoop up
some other characters whether it be
black panther I don't think they would
Daredevil I think they would probably
start making X-Men games at that point
because Spider-Man's been in the X-Men
Universe before hasn't he yeah yeah you
know in the comment box I believe yeah
so I think they could safely bring him
into the act because I think it makes
more sense from like money wise to not
negotiate anymore because clearly you
only got Insomniac really making these
games are you just gonna put like 5 000
people working at Sonia and make 10 15
different comic book games they talked
about expanding them yeah yeah but right
now they're already making two games
that's kind of my point like there's
only so many superhero games you can
make simultaneously I mean I'm just
saying
yeah you make Spider-Man then you make
wolver uh Spider-Man 2. I don't know
Miles Morales and then you uh you make
Wolverine and then that they have a
rumor to be making another game after
Spider-Man 2 comes out yeah and then the
next game would be an iteration a game
with all those units together
um
20 30 when something like that will
happen yeah and especially when you got
the MCU uh writers from the MCU
uh at at um Insomniac helping them with
this as well so and that that's the
biggest thing people say well this isn't
a big deal I bet you if you went back to
DC and you were talking to them when
Iron Man 1 came out and when you know
they're trying to
all these little Marvel IPS that they
did back in the 90s and I bet you you
asked them you know are you scared that
Marvel's gonna make a Cinematic Universe
of some sort they probably would have
told you no but when they made that
first Avengers they tried they're like
oh God we got to make a we gotta make
adjusted League or something like yeah
yep yeah right now you're seeing the
beginning fruits of that type of
Universe for the gaming side and right
now Microsoft has the opportunity to do
something because here I don't think
it's going to be like a huge massive
thing where you can't combat it but I do
think it's going to be extremely massive
and it's going to be that universe is
the by far the reason I own PlayStation
and I that's that's just my fear in the
matter like sooner or later you have
opportunities right now to act but there
will be a time where it will be too late
because you got to build these things up
even if they decided to do it when they
start making these type of games
it's gonna take another you're gonna
have a DC moment with Microsoft where
hopefully they wouldn't but naturally if
you want that kind of results you have
to take that kind of results to make a
game my Sony started in 2018 with the
original Spider-Man probably we won't
see something like this to like 20 30.
that's like 12 years of preparation time
at that time does Microsoft really have
12 you know five ten plus years to get
that same result probably not that's all
you see DC trying to rush out you know a
DC Universe when they ain't really been
able to do it because they didn't they
they want what micro what uh what Marvel
has fought for and grinded for decades
to get
and they want it now and I just don't I
just don't know if Microsoft is going to
be able to Pivot correctly if it does
happen
so I guess I guess we'll get to the uh
to the main event of the evening
PlayStation and Call of Duty okay so
this is pretty much what happened you
know this is the cliff notes
um I don't know exactly maybe you two
gentlemen could educate me 100 on the
the little you don't know your topic
well I know the topic I just don't know
all the little details you don't know
all the details about your topic but I
expect you to show me the details now we
have to show you how to do a yes
bitcloud
I was expecting you to take that 30
minutes that you like and educate
yourself to educate me well pretty much
what happens you know uh
there's an organization that goes around
when companies are being merged and they
decide whether or not it's going to
affect companies from you know competing
well this company's doing the process
that apparently is is normal where they
ask competitors uh you know what would
this purchase or merger it's not a
merger but what would this purchase
affect this industry because a lot of
these people probably even know the
gaming industry like that which is kind
of crazy you would go to Microsoft's
biggest competitor and ask for their
input obviously most likely they're not
cool they're not going to be real with
it man like that
I don't know what do you guys feel on
that one particularly do you think that
if someone went up to ask Sony if they
think because clearly Sony's best
interest is to get this deal cut
so me why would you ask the people that
gained the most out of it being cut
I don't get that what do you guys think
about that first
um
well um
they want the deal because they don't
want Xbox to own Call of Duty
clearly Call of Duty is a very valuable
IP to PlayStation even though it's third
party
um it makes PlayStation hundreds of
millions of dollars yearly they said
that doesn't really yeah yeah I mean
it's very valuable and even though Xbox
has already said that the game will
remain multi-platform
um it seems like they feel that uh you
know Xbox game pass is a threat they
said uh game being full price I'm just
paired I'm paraphrasing here
um a game being full price
when you compare to a service yes that
will hurt those game sales
um
so they're just being honest look man
we're concerned like you know we talk
trash and we say yeah they scared they
scare the real word is concerned to me
the real their concern um
there's so many things
um that can potentially happen
and Call of Duty they depend on it man
they depend on they make lots of lots of
money from Call of Duty uh and they said
even if they tried to build their own
Call of Duty then they broke down
there's 1200 developers each year on
Call of Duty with another 1500 with uh
publishing and whatever else
is too big of a project for their
Studios to do they said this isn't this
is not my words I am paraphrased but
it's not my words it's only worse and um
they say yo man
we the sweetest don't want to you know
we just really don't want to deal with
this we want things to remain how they
are and I mean that's that's how I
that's what I got for me what about you
guys
I mean when they flat I said that this
game can determine uh who who by what's
console yeah I pretty much told you flat
out the significant of how big the deal
is and a lot of people like oh I don't
care about Call of Duty I don't care
about Call of Duty but guess what you
forgot about one major thing about Call
of Duty Call of Duty is populated by
what kids these kids casuals yeah the
main ones buying these damn DLCs they're
the main ones on the zombies they doing
all that stuff so Sony knows this now
the reason why I said it counts more
than just money for Sony uh dirt if you
look at their online
um like engagement numbers
most of that is through Call of Duty
that that takes up a good chunk of it
like when you look at just games online
in general play people play most Chicago
on on the console as it is that's what
casuals flock to they'll go to that for
Call of Duty they'll go to the fifas or
whatever but right that's about it
you'll have those few PlayStation games
that'll break out you have those ones
that are guaranteed like Spider-Man and
then
that's pretty much it it's just like a
rinse and repeat it's the same thing so
the fact that they're like yeah I want
things to remain the same it's
completely understandable you don't want
you don't want to deal with this because
the last thing Sony wants to ever see at
an E3 or whatever show is Microsoft
saying by the way
play Call of Duty only on Xbox Cox they
don't want to see it they don't want to
see that they don't want to see
um you know you pay 70 for us right for
our end you get less to future because
basically what's going to happen that's
basically how this is going to work if
we're talking about uh if we talk about
them keeping it on all platforms they're
gonna they're gonna play this like Chess
at this point where Sony was gonna play
hey yeah uh seventy dollars for the game
according to that division right
whatever they want seven dollars for the
game Microsoft's gonna be like yeah
seventy dollars for PlayStation but uh
game pass users oh it's free by the way
you can you get maps all the DLC you get
that yeah first wow yeah everything
about that part and you go to Legacy
titles they're also here yeah so you get
everything for the low low price so
let's say 25 30 and you know it's money
um let's say that because supposedly
PlayStation's working on like emulating
the PS3
imagine if they work on that and now
because Microsoft owns Activision like
oh you're not emulating Call of Duty
like you yeah you can get these newer
ones that's fine you know uh but we
ain't help we you're we don't get you
don't have our permission to emulate
Black Ops 2 like that that's Xbox if
your place if you if your people want to
play Black Ops 2 on a platform we got a
place for them
oh man
that's right though like you're gonna
see a lot of that
um those plays those strategic you know
underlying type of cuts they're gonna do
it like whenever they get this stuff
done Microsoft's going to have some kind
of counter today going okay well you got
that okay don't expect these games to be
on your list you know they're gonna be
over here but Sony's also going to
probably do something regarding to the
like we saw earlier with the superhero
licenses with um Marvel games so you're
gonna see a lot of them try to outwit
one another in some capacity because
again they're all competing for one
thing market share that's it yeah they
want that market share they want that
market share and when what was
interesting about it too uh when they
talked about how a game pass because you
know everybody likes to remind me and
remind everybody because they don't know
anything about numbers but uh
they'll say Game Pass is a flop it's not
doing anything people are not in it but
then they said that 70 of the market
over here in Brazil is on Game Pass so
it's like
well and then also because y'all forgot
about this Sony mentioned again
mentioned their competitor which is
PlayStation Plus premium they said it
would take them a long time before they
could catch up to something
several years several years so let that
sink in
again it's a lot of stuff yeah you're
right man yeah you're right bro they
they they mentioned that so that
um I agree with everything you said
let's just be honest here no console war
stuff no they're Gregory it being the
Xbox Fanboy stuff none of that stuff
just look at what's going on and Sony is
admitting that it will hurt them
um if XBox owns Call of Duty even though
the game is remaining multiplayer it
will hurt them
um I know there was some PlayStation
guys mad when they said that when Sony
said yo we
um I forgot the word they used where
they said we can't make something that
can rival called arrival we can't yeah
we can't make a successor or something
that can or replicate that we can't
replicate yeah yeah and people like yo
you guys a song you guys make the best
games in the world yes they do they make
great single player games yeah everybody
has their own Specialties yeah so he's
good at the AAA budget single player
games absolutely Microsoft's good at
multiplayer right yeah yeah this
particular developer is good at making
one game mind you one game that drops
yearly at this point or probably every
two years now or right around two years
but they're they're good at making this
one game that drives every two years
with a different number attached to it
and this game is guaranteed to sell
billions or make billions
bro that's where they're at PlayStation
best-selling game pretty much every year
is caught
nah I'm not just talking about because
it's a multi-play no just place to this
PlayStation their best selling game
every year is car that's how important
it is or GTA whenever time those drops
is is those two games those games are
always in the top ten they're all man
even if they could Call of Duty is
overly entrenched so that no rival no
matter how relevant can catch up
so they're pretty much saying because
they broke down how many people
developed the game every year like I
said earlier 1200 people work on each
version and another 1500 are involved in
publishing and distribution Call of Duty
is a huge game massive game and so
somebody's kind of like you know hey man
you know we're not ready for this yet
now like we know they have Bungie they
own Bungie now but like they said it's
going to take it will take time for them
to build something comparable to Call of
Duty which is why I believe you're just
going to see Legacy games that we've
mentioned before or just why Insomniac
tweeted about them and they stopped
ironically what cause I got Governor but
they stopped talking about it or
tweeting about it but we know what's
happening right we saw Socom be
mentioned so resistance Socom are
definitely going to come back at some
capacity Killzone is definitely gonna
have to come back into at this point
because the reason why I say it has to
is because they need Shooters in this
category you see what I'm saying they
need them it's that simple you know they
know they need them that's why they got
a bungee and they're doing some some
live service games they didn't buy they
didn't buy a bungee for no damn
definitely they bought for expertise the
multiplayer that's why Neil druckerman
is so advocated on Sam's actions too is
going to be the biggest thing they've
ever done in terms of how expansive
they've done it because again you have
the expertise of Bungie helping you with
these servers and you got the team going
all out with multiplayer so that has
potential if it's done right to be good
for them but will it be the game that
let's say that's their Gears of War or
multiplayer game is that going to be it
you know I mean it's not going to be the
Breakout game we don't know yet right
they don't know but I would really be a
Betty man and say Socom would be the one
that really pushes that entire thing for
uh for but we'll see yeah see I see uh
let's get this five dollar Super Chat
real quick I got a five dollar Superstar
from gamer by choice appreciate the
generosity man uh yeah if I were the
devs at PlayStation first party I would
be saying what the f you mean we cannot
compete with call that was a slap in the
face I don't okay I don't think they
really meant they couldn't yeah yeah I I
was the way I read that is they were
saying we can't replicate
from like from a sales standpoint they
can't they can make Cod look-alikes
called clones but they can't recreate
the card name that's what I saw that's
exactly what they said because hold on
like add it before you go they also said
um even like a game if they could like
they did make something similar to it
players will be unlikely to switch
they said they will be unlikely to
switch to an alternate game as they
would lose that familiar reality or I I
cannot say that word
yeah those skills and even the friends
they made playing the game even in
weaker years like 2021 cars still
managed to outperform most games by a
considerable margin so they're saying
even if they made something like a new
IP that was comparable to Cod most
people wouldn't switch because Cod is
what they know that's how I took that
right
yeah so guys that's a simple formula
it's a simple formula people just you
know there's nothing else they do they
always find some way to add new
mechanics right but they always keep the
core gameplay yeah the same it's the
same game and they love it bro they love
it and there you go it's like I said I
don't think people realize
how big Cod is like like a lot of people
moved on from that that's the problem
but the thing is y'all moved from moved
on from it and like a whole new
generation has emphasized even more and
that's the thing about college bro I can
say it's dead all day like I'm like oh
Call of Duty it would never be the same
since what Black Ops 2 but still selling
like crazy no like you say war zone save
the French I'm like I don't care about
warism but you know it's good like okay
enjoy Warzone I'm not playing it
it's like I said I
well what's your thoughts addict I think
it's hilarious addict's a mannequin
young we don't want to talk I think it's
hilarious well now it's hilarious though
yeah
that's always been hilarious
look man the fact that Sony comes out
there front stage and Center that says
we can never in a million years make a
Call of Duty replica we could try to
gimmick that [ __ ] but we ain't never
gonna do that [ __ ] like I love it like
it's it's funny like it's like it's like
literally coming after her and emitting
defeat before you even try to admit
defeat like you didn't even step on the
battlefield you're sitting there it's
it's like it's like at least Leonidas
when he went out to Persians I think
that's who he was fighting we're gonna
go with the Persians but when he had the
300 he's like we gonna sit here you
gonna kill us but we going down for
fight PlayStation like now we good we
ain't going on that Battlefield like we
know we ain't fighting that person we
know we ain't beating them and I love it
I love when PlayStation and missed the
feet because because look PlayStation
just ain't meant to feed they're they're
telling their their PlayStation Fanboys
to lower their weapons this isn't a
fight we can win
oh man oh man the days the days relying
on that game over as a crutch or a
clutch a crunch yeah for for PlayStation
yeah
Microsoft what's funny is place that
Microsoft is making PlayStation get off
that that bicycle and they're like oh
that's too small for us man we're about
to make another bicycle like like play
Microsoft just getting on the bike but
they're gonna buy another bike because
PlayStation can't they done use that
bike to death like
it's just like look like it's like I
said I I don't put too much into this uh
you know when it comes to this I do feel
like they were talking mainly about the
name of Call of Duty not you know the
first person uh games that they make I
do feel like that you know it is weird
that they went to someone like Sony like
I can understand going to people that
benefit from Microsoft and I can
understand I don't get going to them or
going to the people that don't benefit
like it's just like I cannot EA
understand that I'm talking to them
Ubisoft understand them talking to them
even Nintendo to a point I still think
that's a little bit interesting but
Nintendo isn't really in that console
Market anymore you know what I'm saying
I really know uh like but to go to Sony
be like yo we know you marketing this
game and we want your input on whether
or not you think it's fair for us to let
for us to but let them buy them so they
can so they can disarm you
like like I'm at like I don't get that
that's the biggest thing like how you
gonna do that like like I felt like you
could talk to everybody but PlayStation
because I don't think you could take
their opinion on it in any way shape or
form because a they're in the same
console selling thing that usually
Microsoft's in and B they have the
marketing for the game of their biggest
game they're trying to buy like so to me
anything they say is is it's like it the
water's tampered with like that's the
part that just that kills me you guys
see uh play uh Xboxes
um
Xbox's response to that
ah
yeah apparently oh yeah yeah I thought
that was I saw it but there's one with
this hilarious
um they pretty much said uh I can't I
don't have it up verbatim but they
pretty much said well
PlayStation took away Spider-Man some
other games
um
pretty much this is a business this is
competition yeah um let me try to find
actual quote
hey hey man what is this Eric the beard
guy in here crying about he's saying um
Sony didn't say what what did Sony say
about car that's false addict I'm
talking about look I'm not well I guess
he was saying that do you reset I can't
I was reading from the put Square
article no it's not that I think he's
saying that they didn't lie so why would
I not take their opinion valid like oh
okay well but if you look at it they
said that I'm not saying that they're
lying about what they said I'm saying
that Sony is biased enough and
PlayStations biased enough where why do
they even go to them in the first place
with that conversation that's what I'm
saying like Sony clearly didn't you know
like speak ill matter we don't know what
was really said we just know what they
quoted but it's just like to me you
don't go let's say Bungie do you go to
Xbox and ask them yo you think it's
right if we let them buy Bungie I don't
think that makes sense okay so I think
you go to more like third-party people
maybe Publishers you know developers too
you could speak to developers but to go
to the number one competition of that
brand and ask them and not only are they
the number one competition that that
brand in that industry they also have
the marketing to the biggest game that
the Company's trying to buy
so that to me it just felt like there
was too much bias to go to Sony in any
way shape or form for this particular
deal
um what Xbox said
they said Sony and Nintendo have strong
and differentiated offerings including
their own exclusive titles for example
IDC has identified that key Sony
exclusive titles in 2018 include god of
war and Marvel Spider-Man in addition to
other prominent titles such as Last of
Us in Uncharted these titles perf I mean
partly reflects Sony's vertical
integration for example Sony's film
studio owns the rights to Spider-Man but
also its broader strategy of obtaining
rights that make third-party games
exclusive to con to its console so
they're saying the Sony in the past they
have their own exclusives and also
they've
uh taking third-party games and made
them exclusive I like Final Fantasy yeah
I mean we yeah most likely you know
especially with the rumors that they
looks like they might be buying Sony uh
score Enix soon you know if that does
come true we never gonna get a uh a
PlayStation game I mean a a Final
Fantasy game and I think that you don't
deserve it you don't buy it I mean I buy
it maybe you don't buy it you know
don't buy well just because you don't
buy games don't mean nobody though you
know that you know that mindset uh dirt
where they say the cheater is always
going to accuse the other one of
cheating uh you know maybe the person
that don't buy the games is gonna be the
one that doesn't buy games that act like
I don't buy games you know I buy games
dirt bike games King plays Game Pass
games but he still pays for that 10
subscription so he even buy what are you
doing bet what are you doing big cloud
I play everything you play everything I
noticed you should play everything you
just say I buy everything so I guess you
just fired oh I do
it's not fired everything no it's it's
jokes you know when it comes down to it
I I just I want
I think that
it makes sense that why they went to
some of these people like Sony I could
understand uh some people did say some
stuff in the chat that like kind of made
me a little bit open up with the
PlayStation being asked maybe ask them
how their business would change if that
were to happen I still don't feel like
because of the biasedness even asking
questions like that like you could
easily say well my company like it
depends on what kind of company it is if
it's a proud company like a Japanese
company or something like that you know
they might they might try to act like
nothing wrong you know they they just
shot a hole in our ship you know it's
thinking a little bit but we find like I
feel like maybe that's okay but uh to me
the biggest thing I'm looking at is just
like you know what did EA say what did
Ubisoft say because keep in mind EA
Ubisoft and you know Activision they
were competitors More Than This the the
big three they were competing with third
party exclusive I mean third-party
platforms and keep in mind they're also
competing with the platforms okay who's
going to get this one who who's giving
you for this one so stuff like that's
going on too I'm curious what EA's got
to say EA probably jumping up and down
we don't got to worry about them anymore
like well they said every every other
publisher they went to was okay with it
except for Sony
that's because Sony has the most to lose
absolutely exactly
so I'm interested to see what they do
because they formed that Capital
alliance with uh from software they
bought shares in the company it's like
one percent two percent in the company
so I don't know what they're going to do
but uh let's see man it's a wrap at this
point you need to go back and get those
Classics and remake them
and it makes you a question big cloud
because you're a PlayStation guy why do
you think just your opinion why do you
think Sony
um stop focusing on some multiplayer
titles last generation because I mean we
know they do single player games
incredible but why do you think they
just like they just focus they stop
focusing on multiplayer titles because
in the PS3 generation they seem to have
a lot more multiplayer titles I mean
well they had some last gen you know
like the last of us we mastered or
Uncharted 4 Killzone so like what's your
answer on that what do you think just
your opinion problem with the PS3 gin
when they were doing it
um you gotta remember PlayStation 3
games horribly sold
first part of us they hardly you
probably have some that sold like four
five million you weren't hitting the
tens and 15s and Twenties that you're
hitting no you know you're not you
weren't hitting that uh back then so
you know when you look at it and that's
what I loved about the PS3 gen because
they were really taking a risk that's
that this was this was Sony taking a
risk to get you to come to that platform
you know I mean they were really being
creative throwing everything out of at
you
um
it's just they I guess they just found
out man they just couldn't they couldn't
sell now when you go to the PS4 gen it
was a lot better A lot a lot of that
leverage they had now because you know
the DRM situation and yeah Microsoft PS4
the castle shows PS4 yeah Microsoft gave
them the best publicity absolutely yeah
I mean I mean when dude's telling you
don't if you don't like to deal with it
I mean yeah they gonna go to the other
platform so so when you had all that and
you know you had a few games coming back
with multiplayer the thing was this
though what does Sony really do you
notice if you want to be like realistic
looking like at the meetings let's look
at the Call of Duty
um the media where the dude from Call of
Duty came out on stage and said yeah by
the way guys all the DLCs exclusive to
PlayStation when it comes out
exclusively first once that deal was
made they stopped caring about moldsburg
because again that's what they knew they
had the biggest
you know third-party game multiplayer
wise on their side plus they had the the
rights they had the Mind share yeah also
yeah yeah because beforehand Microsoft
if you think about Microsoft relied
heavily on that with the 360. heavily
and they just had custom consoles
Halo gears before it's all right the Ed
Haley Goes further but it was mostly the
Call of Duty thing that made you go yo
hey let me say this they had two
straight e3s they started off with Call
of Duty as their first game bro like yup
they was treating Call of Duty like it
was the first yep and you know what's
funny if uh you look at it like my Sony
has low key just said we done was Call
of Duty like we we still have it it's
like that that weird part of the
relationship where the relationship's
over but both people acting like it's
not and like they both low-key looking
for new people but yeah like when you're
looking at the actual relationship it
seems fine but behind closed doors they
hate each other so it's sitting there
like like they're not they're not doing
the red carpet things it's like
equivalent to like Sony watching
watching their wife which is Call of
Duty go over there mingle with with
Microsoft and come back acting like that
[ __ ] didn't just happen you know what
they're just sitting there looking for
it and they just waiting for them to
break up formally break up like yeah
that's why you know again as I mentioned
to see what Bungie brings to the table
uh with the next Destiny how they how
they advertise Destiny and how they are
about it too I already tell you exactly
how they're going to advertise that's it
they already did it once before uh
what's funny is the beginning of last
generation Microsoft couldn't even
acknowledge the fact that but the
Destiny was coming on the the yeah
they had to do like weird stuff like
like weird like like that cologne bottle
yeah
something like that yeah
I see that happening you're like you
know when it comes to
everything in that I don't think that
you know you know what we should be
worried about more than this how are we
in August
and we still have a date for Sony's
yearly like E3 type of show like we in
August well I did a video on Nets uh
yeah I think it's gonna happen but at
the same time I don't think it will
happen oh yeah I think it might not
happen
after that issue I don't know if y'all
saw it um but basically there was like a
issue involving a laptop that got stolen
a program
it's like it's like over 100 gigs of
data for their upcoming stuff
so basically everything for the last of
us remake that got shown to
um by shrapnel I do a shrapnel Nick he
got sent that that was from that laptop
um that was from the files in their
laptop and guess what another game that
was mentioned on that was God of War
right I don't know what's I don't know
what they're going to do for this
and a lot of people were trying to
dismiss me it's not happening but I'm
like a lot of people were coming out
saying that this is uh more likely the
case of why they're quiet and why
they're being very very cryptic now that
they've ever done because
uh I don't know how that happens we use
a lot but oh that sucks bro that sucks I
do you guys think that that's concerning
if they don't have a show
um with the content they dropped alone
is enough
you know I really know about the road
map of Sony right now we know Wolverine
that's gonna be 2024 probably since
2023. that's next year that's all
it's about to miss next year it's
Wolverine this 2024 you got you really
think Wolverines come out 2024
at this rate was insomniacia no I
believe with insomnia see here's the
thing though but like but what about
like what else I see Wolverine 2025
that's where I see Wolverines because
here they have to make a new battle
system for Wolverine they can't have
them be like sliding on buildings and
stuff like like it was like he's got to
have a new battle system
yeah unless they're going with like the
Logan style third person
where it's like dark gritty and guts
everywhere which would be kind of
interesting so what what besides that
you know they they CL supposedly the way
that
they were
go and someone said I stay I straight
away from uh Wolverine I talked about
Wolverine thank you
um the way that they're going through
this stuff
um it looks like Egypt because we
thought there that Kratos is going to go
to Egypt after this game but the way
that that chick on Twitter worded it it
kind of made it seem like he's going to
Egypt in this game
uh so it's going to be interesting how
they do that but like normally here's
the reason I'm a little skeptical on on
what's going on with Sony and
PlayStation
normally they have no problem coming out
and say yeah this is in 2027. this is in
2026 like obviously not the dates but
they have no problem coming out there
and just dropping Mike after Mike and
say these games are coming out we don't
know when we don't know what we you
gotta couldn't get too much info out of
them but they're coming out that's our
road map leave us alone we'll see you
next year with gameplay to one of them
and then walk off the stage
they don't they haven't really done that
like we've seen Spider-Man and Wolverine
I see Wolverines would be a little bit
more in that vein because I think that
game's probably 20 20 maybe late 2024
early 2025 but as far as that this is
the first time since I've been covering
gaming which is like 2014-ish that we
don't know a lot about Sony's games at
all like at all
we don't know the majority of those 10
player uh games which there are I think
some of them are probably out like Ryan
Turismo those games is the service games
we don't know the majority of those
we don't know what the majority of their
actual studios are making
it's weird like and they're the kind of
company that you would think it's a
grand slam they're gonna go make uh goes
to sushima too but there are also the
companies say gotcha and make a new IP
so I'm it's interesting that people keep
saying
they don't have enough to show but I'm
sitting here screaming what have they
shown to not have enough to show you
know what I'm saying
well let's be
um honest well like the last two years
they their show dropped in September so
it's early August I'm assuming they're
going to announce it sometime this month
now if that doesn't happen okay now we
can start okay let's
let's see what's going on um I'm just
like
we're guessing that we're is is August
3rd let's just wait to see I'm assuming
they're going to let people know this
sometime this month about the show
yeah like I said if they don't
yeah let's be real okay okay dirt I got
I want it I want to ask you a question
yeah they we we finish September August
and we in September like mid-september
yeah are you gonna clown them for not
making a show be honest yeah now I'm
gonna be absolutely honest with you if
if we make it to August 31st and they
haven't announced the show
I'm gonna have some fun
but I'm expecting them too though I'm
expecting them too Bitcoin would you be
disappointed if they didn't have a show
this year
no because I have tons of games before
Oh you sound like an Xbox player
um I will feel a certain way because
like
the last show we had focused strictly on
VR here's the fun thing about the VR
show we didn't get the pricing for VR
at all nor do we even know when it's
dropping
I'm thinking it's gonna be 500 bro what
you think I've been saying that too
around five like the way they've been
pushing their cinematic modes the way
that the quality is the quality is
really really good yeah
I could definitely see five yeah you got
a few bro two dollars from Spartan go
17. Sony cried with Jason Trump
down bad he's saying Sony is down bad
because what's going on another two
dollars from Spartan ghost 17. Sony
literally threw their teams under the
bus so I guess he's pretty much saying
yo you saying all your teams are not as
uh you know none of them could make
something as quality as Call of Duty
which I get it I think you can literally
interpret that as well in many ways as
you want me particularly I don't think
they were really talking about the the
like the Call of Duty as a whole they
were talking about the brand I think
that's what they're talking about it's
an established brand and it's gonna be
hard it's a hard game like let's be real
here yeah besides Call of Duty the only
other games that I could see eventually
hitting that thrive
yeah well GTA I think is even above Call
of Duty at this point like yeah it is
yeah it is yeah because well sure GTA
don't drop games but they are very
respected thing I'm saying like first
person shooter I think valorant could
get Call of Duty a run for its money
sure it's not it probably don't make as
much money by far but I do think it's
got that respect that Call of Duty has
on the PC side yeah on the PC side you
know you know what's you know I was
really annoyed a little bit shout outs
we have 300 people in the chat man hit
that like button let's get that up to
100. hit that like button let's get that
to 150. I I was annoyed that when they
did all that stuff at that event with
Microsoft that they didn't announce
Valor coming to the console that's what
I thought was gonna happen you know
you would never catch me involved let me
point that out right now I will never be
invalid because it is one of the most
sweaty games in existence I don't go
there to pull my hair as you can see my
hairline is pretty far back there I
don't need to pull any hair out it's
like it's coming out by itself so that
I'm definitely not attic values is beard
people yeah yeah I do value my beard man
I do I need to trim it up man let's get
a little out of hand but you know that
that's besides the fact we got five
dollar super trap from uh Duran durian
Dorian Gray Dorian Grays I can't wait
for the first card game on PlayStation 5
after
yo imagine if you if you loaded up Call
of Duty
and then and then it first off it's
gonna have it's gonna have whoever's
making it and then probably the second
screen is going to be Activision and
Xbox at the bottom Xbox game studios
yeah because even even like when I
played the show seeing that PlayStation
Studios pop up on the Xbox hey man it is
what it is at this point
oh my God man you know besides the fact
you know I I definitely you know I
appreciate you guys as a super chat so
you know definitely funds the show uh
damn Joker comes out in 2024. yeah I saw
that
Joker too
oh the movie the movie Walking Walking
Phoenix [ __ ] that's cool you know it's
like I said I think the future looks
bright you know we're gonna go ahead and
close the show off first thing I want to
ask you guys is what games are you
looking forward to in the next six
months because I'm looking at the
beginning of next year and the end of
this year and it's pretty stacked like
it really is like what games are you
guys particularly looking for keep in
mind we still don't have a date for
Harry Potter that's kind of crazy like
yeah that's awesome on my that's on my
radar as well but um the game I've said
I'm like the most hyped for to end this
year in general it would be Kalisto
protocol
for sure and then the beginning
definitely Destiny's remake I love what
they're doing uh with that and then we
also have uh obviously Harry Potter but
um
wrestling even before man Resident Evil
4 remake I never finished that game in
the past man I never you never you never
be residential
man kick him off the pedal but listen
hold on let me tell you something let me
tell you something my first Resident
Evil let me tell you something the first
I'm a different type of gamer nowadays
or I didn't finish a lot of games in my
20s I'm a different type of gamer the
first Resident Evil game I'm completely
finished was seven
then I finished you know Village then I
finished though the Remake two and three
so I just didn't finish games back then
but I do now and I'm looking forward to
the Remake part four remake never finish
it back then I think you'll like it like
here's the thing about right no I will
yeah Resident Evil 4. people say oh it's
it's more action than horror like people
really sitting here acting like a like a
zombie apocalypse is gonna be nothing
but horror the whole time during that
look zombie apocalypse is gonna be a lot
of horror towards the opening scenarios
of a zombie apocalypse when you're in
cities when you're walking through stuff
when you're not trying to get killed
it's not gonna stay that way first off
diseases mutate look at what we're in
now they mutate all the time uh you're
gonna see stuff like this actually
happen if something like this war to
happen sure not every way that happens
in Resident Evil and I can understand
why some people didn't really gravitate
towards because it wasn't more of the
horror aspects but Resident Evil 4 is by
far the best Resident Evil and that's
just my opinion like yeah I know but
here's the thing I can say Resident Evil
2 and 3 are solid good games great games
even but to me four just had so much and
a lot of it had a lot of depth to it you
know I mean even the fight with krauser
like the blade fiber crowser and all
that stuff it's like dude this this is
they were just having fun with the
lights at that point it was a lot of
dope moments in for that's what I'm
hyped for it I'm hyped to see what they
do because I'm wondering is Ashley going
to be the same like she was in the
original it doesn't look like she's
going to be the same like they're going
a completely different route pretty much
Ashley Dart was like just someone that
you had to protect like the typical
dancing in distress I played it I
actually made it when I like when it
finally came out on the PS2 after the
GameCube exclusivity I bought it I
played it up until the point where you
actually get Ashley and I don't know why
I just kind of stopped playing I'm not
sure why but she's probably at the
church where you had to get it yeah
that's where I'm at that's like where
I'm at yeah I just stopped playing or
something I don't know what happened
I think you should I think I will too
because listen let me tell you something
I and I
enjoyed seven Village the two remakes I
enjoyed all of them um so I'm and I
finished all of them so I'm definitely
looking forward to them protocol that's
gonna be a good one absolutely what you
see Silas are that's why I'm getting
ready to see y'all yeah his design like
the little kid who's basically like 90
years old but he's yeah yeah I remember
him it's gonna be good man I I have a
lot of Hope for resident before I do
yeah I actually forgot it was coming
like like what February or what like
March or something like that yeah Dead
Space is February we have a good six
months of gaming like a really good six
months of gaming and then we got God of
War in November as long as they don't
get pushed back yep actually no I'm
sorry I'm sorry Dead Space remake is
January I think it's January I believe
January yeah cholesterol protocol in
December is December yeah that's right I
think this might be
like one of the best like six months
because I think we'll ID guys this year
been kind of rough for me man it's
definitely been true I've been having
I've been having to like dive into the
ocean put pick up every Rock like look
for any gym whatsoever I could play
That's mildly entertaining like you know
you got myself so bad on playing 16 bit
games you know like I'm not I was that
area but like I say that a lot of the
16-bit games that are made Modern days
are killing it they're so good
well well you know with me you know by
me being about you know first party's
obviously been dry this year
um XBox people definitely got to figure
out some unique ones yeah I've been
playing hey I've been playing um you
know I I did finish as thus far I
enjoyed it you know he's like pretty
much but I I enjoyed it I finished that
I've been trying to uh play uh like
finish large judgment how I mentioned
earlier I went back to play The Last of
Us too because I when I finished it in
2020 I was just kind of rushed through
it just to review it that's why I rushed
through it but this time I'm taking my
time with it and uh yeah man but I'm
like you guys I'm excited for I'm
excited for Modern Warfare too because
they're claiming this is going to be one
of the best Call of Duties ever I'm a
campaign I'm a Kai campaign guy I don't
really play the multiplayer too much
some PlayStation guy you know he pulled
my father you don't even play the
multiplayer Lucas I said shut up punk
I play the campaigns right I'm not much
of a car multiplayer but I'm looking
forward to that looking forward to God
of War Ragnarok Kalisto protocol that's
that might be my most exciting
um game this year besides god of war and
next year hey man resident before we
make I'm agreeing with everything you
guys said they showed me with this yeah
yeah man like I'm like damn I haven't
seen games like gritty in a long time
like it looks good man them kills all
goodness yeah
that was crazy that was good it really
captured his face like oh this dude I'm
about to go into this reactor and as you
guys see my background
I love Arcane games I don't know if it's
going to come out the first quarter of
uh 2023 I think it will I love I think I
love Arcane games and I can't wait for
real far I think you'll probably feel
good you needed more polish I think you
might see a redfall and star filled uh
release date at the Video Game Awards oh
that'd be fire and I yeah actually um
I'm expecting death Loop to drop this
year for Xbox
games soon like yes yeah because they
said they can't mention nothing because
PlayStation had the year exclusivity
I believe Tim Dogg said on Twitter he
said he heard that it's definitely
coming this year but they can't mention
anything because your PlayStation has
the year exclusive deal I'm definitely
looking forward to all of that man so
let's go how much smoke Xbox is gonna
have the moment that exclusivity ends oh
that's what's over on here and what
watch watch they have been having Arcane
work on like a huge expansion for death
Loop and Knowing damn well that the game
probably isn't gonna do that well like
sales wise just so they can say the best
place to play Death Loop is on our
platform is atlas all right we're gonna
go ahead and end this man I appreciate
everyone come through we had up to
almost 315 20 people in here we had a
great show you know first thing I want
to say is I appreciate for uh you know
all uh for the panel members to come
here they come in here every week to uh
entertain you guys Dirk griggity where
can people find you at what do you got
going on uh nothing much man you know
had a good podcast a couple nights ago
had a lot of fun uh just check out my
channel man I'm a pro Xbox Channel we do
talk a lot of trash uh you know but I
don't hate PlayStation of course I do I
only care for the ponies too much but
you know it's all good man just check
out my channel when you guys get the
chance press Alpha dope and what what
what's bigcloud doing
big cloud is playing games chilling but
you can find him on this Shadow big
cloud gaming you can also find me a
twitch Twitter same thing big cloud
gaming obviously uh Lords gaming.net
find me there and IGN as one of the
curators for uh playlist
I just like I said I want to appreciate
everyone coming through what I am going
to do is I have been uh messing a little
bit with uh how the redirect features
works I want to highlight other content
creators that I do feel like don't get
the shine that they should so after the
podcast it should be directed to fame
over there at level one gaming I don't
know if it's gonna work I think it's
gonna work
but I think it's like a 30 like a 50 50
thing so if you go over there man uh
definitely I I don't know we're about to
find out so uh definitely putting the
chat man tell them IOP addict show sent
you man I hope uh you know what no tell
them attic show since you're not IOP
addicts uh so I appreciate everyone
coming through and until next week we
outta here